mattias wrote in saying I often hear
people say you can't have democracy
without free speech but I don't really
understand that can you explain right so
here's the confusion some people have
democracy is voting put quite simply
representative democracy different types
of democracy the will of the people
being reflected in policy and our
elected officials that seems different
than speech so why is free speech so
important in democracy basically that in
in the simplest terms and different
people will define this different ways
in simplest terms if you don't have a
right to free speech if you don't have a
censorship free society you are not
going to have full discussions of all of
the political issues of the candidates
that are out there you might not have
all sides equally heard in talking about
what their positions are about any
particular issue as soon as you don't
have total free speech that sort of of
course direct incitement to violence
which can be criminalized as they are in
the United States when you can't have a
full and open debate about political
issues then the voting that you are
participating in is not properly and
fully democratic if not if there are not
open airings of political positions and
full debate that is unrestricted by
limits on speech then the voting that
takes place is not fully democratic
either because ideas were not fully
fleshed out or heard or maybe even
suppressed to some degree and that's
sort of the gist of it and you can get
more micro and say well does it apply to
voters having speech or does it apply to
the candidates having speech or does it
apply to media fairness and the answer
is sort of all of the above it can apply
to all of those things but at its most
core level if speech is limited than the
Democratic than the participation and
that democracy is not really full and
fair and thus you don't really have that
democracy that you claim to have that
that's the idea and we could really
flesh it out more matias but that's
generally speaking what we mean by
without free speech you don't really
have democracy